y nosotros llegamos entonces a quito la
capital ecuatoriana porque la fuerza
para olave don calificó de legal la
detención del dirigente y principal
promotor de las protestas contra el
gobierno guillermo lasso pero lo dejó en
libertad condicional al imponer medidas
que reemplazan a la prisión provisional
como la prohibición por ejemplo de la
salida del país y la presentación
periódica ante una autoridad competente
conectamos entonces con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital ecuatoriana
gustavo ortega gustavo lo saludo muy
buena mañana de miércoles de cuáles son
entonces los detalles de la decisión
judicial que dejó en libertad a leonidas
iza y cuál ha sido la reacción de los
colectivos indígenas
sí muy buenos días para ti tales como tú
lo habías dicho luego de la audiencia de
calificación de flagrancia que realizará
la jueza posteriormente
su fallo fue a favor de ordenar la
liberación inmediata de leonidas iza la
fiscalidad ha pedido también medidas
alternativas a la prisión preventiva en
principio se había pedido inclusive la
prisión preventiva pero posteriormente
su equipo abogado se introdujo en su
diligencia judicial
unos recursos los cuales ordenaban la
liberación inmediata a la decisión de la
juez posteriormente también será
procesado en libertad por el presunto
delito de paralización del servicio
público recordemos que quizás había sido
detenido la madrugada del martes y
posteriormente su detención como fue
detenido si fue legal o no su detención
si se leyeron los derechos o no se les
dieron los derechos y amplias
movilizaciones masivas han estado en
torno a esta detención de dirigente
indígena leonidas iza lo cierto es que
la jueza también admitió el trámite a
solicitud de medidas cautelares
presentadas por la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos este
será de igual forma entonces procesado
en libertad deberá presentarse los días
miércoles y viernes ante la autoridad
legal igual forma se espera que la
audiencia sea realizada el próximo 4 de
julio en cuanto a las reacciones que
tuve comentado bueno esto ha tenido
muchas reacciones tanto nacionales como
internacionales pero precisamente sus
adherentes y seguidores se han convocado
desde muy temprano el día de ayer
básicamente la unidad quizás sale en
libertad la madrugada del día de hoy y
su primera declaración lo que he dicho
es que el que considera que esto es una
persecución política ha sido más un caso
político que también de tipo judicial
mientras el ejecutivo nacional asegura
que él más bien ha cometido un delito de
flagrancia lo cierto es que leonidas iza
ha dicho que se convoca en consejo
permanente de las organizaciones
indígenas existe este momento
paralización en ciertos sectores del
territorio nacional y se espera
inclusive el desarrollo de este consejo
de las organizaciones indígenas raúl
gustado también tras el arresto de isa
se hizo un llamado a la radicalización
de ésta protesta esto se mantiene tras
su liberación ha gustado y también que
esperar de estas protestas en los
próximos días
si precisamente luego que sale a
leonidas iza en su primera declaración
lo que ha dicho es que continúa la lucha
específicamente he dicho el dirigente
indígena recordamos que el día de ayer
las distintas bases de las
confederaciones nacionalidades indígenas
de ecuador llamaban a radicalizar como
tú lo has indicado eso quiere decir
desplazarse a las principales ciudades
del país para el día de hoy se esperaba
inclusive que las movilizaciones
permanecieran en gran protestas
caminarán hacia la capital ecuatoriana y
en la ciudad de guayaquil pero para el
día de hoy se conoce que incluso estas
movilizaciones han sido movidas para el
día jueves todo esto porque la unidad
quizá ha llamado a un consejo del
gobierno de las distintas bases de la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de ecuador para tener así un
resultado pero ha destacado en su
primera declaración de que se mantiene
la lucha y sobre todo no ha paralizado
las protestas y sobre todo siguen
demandando en sus diez puntos que
demandan en contra del ejecutivo
nacional raúl gustavo como siempre
gracias a por toda la información
la capital de ecuador